did you ever think when you were you
started modeling and you were doing all
these fun things did you ever think I'm
going to make it I'm going to be an
actor I'm gonna be known I'm gonna be
famous I'm gonna make money did you
honestly did you ever think like that I
did good for you to say that I well and
you know of course you're young so
you're like I'm by this age gonna get
this by age 28 I'm going to have an Emmy
and an Oscar and all you know what I
mean of course it was like this thing by
30 I'm going to be married it's like all
of these you know things and then you
get in the real world and you're like
that's not how this works yeah um and I
really like weirdly when I first started
in Hollywood 2 I had this version of
course because it was like you know the
time of before cell phones it was the
time of photographers following you
around and and [__] like that so it was
like I had this weird thing in my head
was like well if you don't have
photographers following you around then
obviously you're not successful you know
know it was just this really weird like
you know I should be like Lindsay loan
nobody wants that um
but that shifted I mean that shifted
when I was like really working and going
I like to do this and I also like my
life that's why I live in
Austin you know what I mean so you
stopped wanting to you weren't chasing
Fame anymore you were just enjoying the
moment yes and it took me some time to
that takes time because you kind of uh
Revel in it or whatever you kind of uh
just want to be noticed and have
attention and things that I didn't get
as a kid and and all of a sudden you get
that and you get that and you realize
it's kind of just comes and goes and no
one really cares and but I still like I
still like getting recognized I don't I
don't it doesn't phase me but it go I I
still go that's cool that's nice no
definely an appreciation for it
absolutely it just doesn't Define my
life anymore because that's the thing
too I mean I know you guys are in LA but
that's what I don't love about it is the
incestuous nature of the city that every
single person pretty much is in one
industry it's like even if you're a
lawyer you're you know working for a
studio or it just so everything's
measured everything's a dick measuring
contest right oh I went on this audition
today I got this i got this you know
what I mean all your friends you're like
yeah you start to really have a lot of
self-hate because you're like I'm
measuring myself based on other people
and their successes you know yeah I I I
get that um I think that you know for so
long it's like when people come up to
you and they're like hey so what's new
and for so long it was like oh well I
got this going on and I got this going
on and I think this is going to happen
and I'm probably going to do this and
you just had to always feel important
and I swear to God everything has
shifted where where people are like uh
hey what are you up to I'm like you know
what I'm just enjoying life I'm just
enjoying whatever I do trying to have an
element of fun and anything I do I'm
just trying to
be you know present present hey guys I'm
doing another live podcast downtown LA
at the Regent Theater and my special
guest for January 24th is Kristen Ritter
Breaking Bad Jessica Jones this is going
to be a sold out event I know it it's
going to be exciting and uh there's a
meet and greet and so much fun that's
going to happen January 24th so make
sure you get tickets as soon as possible
downtown Los Angeles at the Regent
inside of you with Michael rosenbom with
special guest Kristen Ritter I'm so
excited